♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
LIKE A LOT OF ACTORS, MATT
DAMON HAS A WEAKNESS FOR
SILLY FASHIONABLE POLITICS.
OTHERWISE, HE SEEMS LIKE A
DECENT ENOUGH GUY.
CERTAINLY BY THE STANDARDS
OF THE WORLD HE LIVES IN
WHERE THE BUSINESS WHERE
STARS OFTEN BEHAVE LIKE
LONG CONSIDERED A MORAL
LEADER MATT DAMON STANDS
OUT.
HE IS APPARENTLY WELL LIKED
BY EVERYBODY HE DEALS WITH.
HE GIVES GENEROUSLY TO
CHARITIES.
HE HAS BEEN MARRIED TO THE
RAISING FOUR DAUGHTERS.
NO ONE HAS EVER EVEN ACCUSED
HIM OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
SUDDENLY THAT DOESN'T MATTER
MATT DAMON'S CAREER IS IN
SIGNED A PETITION FOR
CALLING FOR PRODUCERS TO CUT
DAY MONDAY FROM LATEST FILM.
THAT MOVIE HAS ALREADY BEEN
BOOTH.
OTHER PEOPLE ARE SAYING DAY
MONDAY OUGHT TO BE DENIED
FUTURE FILM ROLES AND HE
MAY.
WHAT DID HE DO TO DESTROY
HIS REPUTATION IN SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
LAST WEEK HE GAVE AN
INTERVIEW ABC NEWS ABOUT THE
WAVE OF SEX SCANDALS IN
HOLLYWOOD.
NO, HE DIDN'T DEFEND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THAT
INTERVIEW.
HE DIDN'T SUGGEST THE
ACCUSERS ARE LYING.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING
REMOTELY LIKE THAT.
THOUGH YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW
IT FROM THE COVERAGE WHICH
IN SOME CASES OMITS ANY OF
DAMON'S DIRECT QUOTES.
MATT DAMON'S VIEWS.
HERE IS WHAT HE ACTUALLY
SAID TO ABC NEWS.
>> I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
A SPECTRUM OF BEHAVIOR,
RIGHT, AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT LIKE
WHAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN, YOU
KNOW, PATTING SOMEONE ON THE
BUTT AND RAPE OR CHILD MOW
LESS TATION, RIGHT?
BUT, THEY SHOULDN'T BE
SAY WE LIVE IN CULTURE OF
OUTRAGE AND INJURY AND HAVE
TO CORRECT ENOUGH TO SAY
WE ARE IN THE MOMENT, AT THE
CLEARER SIGNAL TO MEN AND
YOUNGER PEOPLE IS DENY IT
BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT YOU
DID, YOUR LIFE IS GOING TO
END OF THE CONTINUUM WHERE
HAVE YOU RAPE AND CHILD
MOLESTATION OR WHATEVER, YOU
KNOW, THAT'S PRISON.
THAT'S CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AND
IT NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH
THAT WAY.
THE OTHER STUFF IS KIND OF
SHAMEFUL AND GROSS.
I DON'T KNOW LOUIE CK I
NEVER MET HIM.
I'M NOT FASTEN HIS.
I DON'T IMAGINE HE IS GOING
TO DO THOSE THINGS AGAIN.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I IMAGINE THE PRICE HE HAS
PAID AT THIS POINT IS SO
BEYOND ANYTHING THAT HE -- I
THINK WE HAVE START
DELINEATING WHAT THESE
BEHAVIORS ARE END QUOTE.
THERE IT IS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
INCOMPLETE THOUGHTS IN
PUBLICIST WOULD ADVISE YOU
AGAINST EXPRESSING IN
PUBLIC.
BE HONEST, HOW MUCH OF THAT
DO YOU ACTUALLY DISAGREE
WITH?
HOW MUCH IS HATEFUL OR
IMMORAL OR OTHERWISE BEYOND
THE PALE?
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
SENTIMENT IN THAT ENTIRE
PARAGRAPH THAT'S NOT
DEFENSIBLE OR 90% OF THE
POPULATION WOULD FIND OVER
THE TOP OR OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT, BECAUSE A HANDFUL OF
TWITTER USERS DON'T LIKE IT,
THE REST OFS HAVE YOU TO
PRETEND THAT MATT DAMON IS
SOMEHOW GUILTY OF SOMETHING
AWFUL.
IF WE DON'T PRETEND, WE MAY
CRIMES HE SUPPOSEDLY
COMMITTED AND FORCED TO
CORRUPTING.
THIS IS HOW REASONED GUYS,
WE ARE WATCHING IT HAPPEN.
MOST OF US ARE TOO AFRAID TO
SAY ANYTHING ABOUT IT AS IT
HAPPENS.
MEANWHILE THE MOST
REASONABLE VOICES GET LOUDER
BY THE HOUR.
YESTERDAY ACTRESS ROSE
MCDID YOU GOEN ORDERED ET
CLAIMS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVERYONE
ACCUSED IS GUILTY.
IF YOU DENY THAT YOU ARE
GUILTY TOO.
WEIRDLY ALMOST NOBLE IN THE
MEDIA PUSHED BACKS AGAINST
ROSE McDID YOU GOEN'S
GHANTD DEMAND.
BEFORE LONG THEY HAVE TO
FOLLOW HER SHE HAS NEARLY A
MILLION TWITTER FOLLOWERS.
SHE IS CALLING THE SHOTS.
LET'S BE HONEST WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
POPULATION AND IRONICALLY
THEY TEND TO BE THE BEST
EDUCATED PORTIONS OF THE
WAGONING, SOCIAL MEDIA DID
EVERY FAMOUS PERSON IN
AMERICA IS THINKING AT ALL
FACEBOOK PRESIDENT SEAN
PARKER ADMITTED THE WEBSITE
HE HELPED FOUND FACEBOOK
QUOTE LITERALLY CHANGES YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH SOCIETY
AND WITH EACH OTHER.
PARKER WAS RIGHT.
IT IS ALL SHREDDING OUR
SOCIAL FABRIC BEFORE OUR
EYES.
REMEMBER, YOU HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO SAY WHAT
YOU THINK IS TRUE.
OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT NOT AGREE
EVIL OR MEAN YOU OUGHT TO BE
FIRED FROM YOUR JOB.
IT JUST MEANS YOU DISAGREE.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN TRUE.
TRUE NOW.
JOINING US NOW RADIO SHOW
HOST TAMMY BRUCE.
SO, TAMMY, I NEVER THOUGHT
THAT I WOULD DEFEND MATT
DAMON AND I'M NOT ACTUALLY
REALLY DEFENDING MATT DAMON,
I'M DEFENDING THE
PROPOSITION THAT YOU SAY
SOMETHING THAT OTHER PEOPLE
DISAGREE WITH WITHOUT BEING
>> YEAH, INDEED.
LOOK, I ALSO LOATHE HIM.
HE SAID SOME THINGS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT AND ABOUT
OTHERS WHICH POLITICALLY I
VERY MUCH DISAGREE WITH.
I DON'T KNOW HIM.
BUT HE SEEMS TO ME TO BE
LIKE THE BLIND SQUIRREL
HERE.
EVERY NOW AND THEN YOU FIND
A NUT.
AND HE HAS FOUND ONE BECAUSE
HE IS RIGHT.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN
YOUR ASSESSMENT LEADING INTO
THIS.
BUT AS A FEMINIST, HERE IS
ALSO WHAT I SEE IN THIS
REGARD.
I HAVE BEEN ARGUING FROM THE
BEGINNING HERE THAT WE NEED
TO BE CAREFUL AS I SAW THE
ARE ACTUAL PREDATORS.
AND THE WOMEN INVOLVED IN
THIS AND THE PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT ARGUE THAT WELL WE
DON'T WANT HIM AND OTHERS TO
TRIVIALES
TRIVIALsS
TRIVIALs THESE SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS.
WHAT REALLY TRIVIALIZES
THEM, TUCKER, WHEN YOU DO
COMPARE A MAN CALLING YOU
BEAUTIFUL AS YOU WALK DOWN
THE HALLWAY OR MAYBE RUBBING
SURVIVORS, WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN THROUGH.
AND I THINK AS MOST PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT, AS WE
LISTEN TO AS YOU READ WHAT
CHALLENGE.
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT THE
LEFT ALWAYS DOES.
THEY USE A SERIOUS ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE, WE KNOW IT HAS
TO BE DEALT WITH.
AND THEN WRITE IT AND THEN
ABUSE IT, THEY GO TOO FAR.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE FRENCH
REVOLUTION.
PEOPLE BEGIN TO DO THINGS
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CAN.
AND THEY USE IT FOR REVENGE
OR BECAUSE THEY CAN'T STOP
THEIR RAGE.
AND THEN EVERYBODY IS GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY -- JODY
FOSTER I HAVE THINK SAID I
SAW A HEADLINE THE OTHER DAY
THAT EVERY MAN OVER THE AGE
OF 30 IS SOMEWHAT CULPABLE
FOR THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT WE
NOW FACE.
I HAVE FOUND IN MY LIFE IT'S
BEEN MEN WHO HAVE BEEN MOST
HELPFUL AND THE MOST DECENT
TO ME.
WITH WOMEN NOT NECESSARILY
BEHAVIOR.
IT'S ABOUT CONTROL.
I THINK THAT UNLESS WE GET A
HANDLE ON THIS AND HAVE AN
HONEST CONVERSATION, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE LEFT ONCE
AGAIN SHREDDING AN IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW,
THEY HAVE NO BOUNDARY OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND THEN CONFLATING
EVERYTHING AND THEN JUST
SIMPLY VOMITING THEIR RAGE
OUT ON EVERYONE.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
IT DIMINISHES THE EXPERIENCE
WOULD SAY WE BOTH SUFFERED
IN A SAME WAY.
YOU SAY ACTUALLY I HAD MY
LEG BLOWN OFF.
YOU BROKE A FINGER.
THEY ARE NOT THE SAME.
>> THERE ARE DIFFERENT
THINGS IN THE WORKPLACE AND
SERIOUSNESS.
WORKPLACES CLEARLY ARE
DEALING WITH THAT WE HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL WITH SINGLE
VOICES WHO HAVE PERHAPS
ORIGINALLY SOME VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS TO SAIL AND
SHOULD NOT BE CONFLATED.
THESE THINGS ARE DIFFERENT.
THERE IS A CONTINUUM.
AND CERTAIN VOICES,
HOPEFULLY VOICES LIKE OURS
WILL REMIND PEOPLE OF THESE
THINGS AND MAKE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE A WHOLESALE
EFFECTIVELY A BEHEADING OF
EVERYONE WHO THE LEFT
DOESN'T LIKE OR THAT
FEMINISTS DON'T LIKE BECAUSE
THEN WE ARE ALL GOING TO
LOSE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.